I mean why is Capitan
[Music]
so thank you thank you yes
yes I know you're ignoring me Gertie
I am I'm still mad at you yes of course
I don't know why you're so mad at me on
the Sprinter van when you were like oh
why are you looking at me don't look at
me like that
face
no you're like
with the wedding I felt really dismissed
unappreciated when you said to me
everyone's party was okay but like
marisol's party was the best of all of
them and your charity event was okay but
I need you to make sure that my party is
like top top ten I'm like I do
top-notches I'm at the plaza I'm at the
pier like I'm everywhere super
insensitive because you knew my
situation so you knew that I didn't get
married because my mother died yeah my
wedding yes
okay I'm fine okay so so you know okay
and I cry with Russell that same day
when you talked about my charity event
and comparing it to Marisol
I didn't okay when you give Alexia too
much sympathy and empathy and then she
says oh I'm not a victim oh but when he
serves her right oh my God no
I know I mean listen I want drama queen
two in in college and in high school by
the way so that with the gold toe-to-toe
all day long with this whole charade the
fact that you abandoned me after a year
that it took me to get married and
you're like oh I have a wedding I
abandoned you I asked you what is the
date and I was already broke
unfortunately but then you showed up to
party
in the Sprinter your behavior was
disgusting and unacceptable
you know because you're like Exorcist
you're like oh
my God doing all this stuff and like oh
my God and I was like wait did I say
something what the [ __ ] are you what are
you talking about in this winter now
your reactions I know you're like the sh
are you doing your face
wow ma'am no no when you're sitting
across from her it's it's it's it's
scary it's scary oh you can't read my
face really okay let me explain what's
happening here this is happy this is mad
I didn't know
again what that emotion was
no I don't know did you see me move
[ __ ] Alexa I've seen like this but
Gertie where did this granny come from
full of yourself
but why are you so defensive why do you
think everybody's out to get you all
right no one has calm them knocked down
these girls have no consideration no
respect in a day that is so crucially
important to me like that I would never
tell why would you say that what would
you think sunlight's going down we don't
have a lot of time left to get the
shooting done wait for the light to be
over and then fight all you want throw
each other aboard
do whatever you want but let's get the
video done first I'm going to give you a
comparison it's going to hurt and you
may not like it my brother 10 11 years
later
exactly so then why are you trying to
like say that I'm trying to put your
brother down what I'm saying to you is
that my brothers it's like no Touchstone
I am
iron
the charity equals my brother Jimmy so
when you measure the Jared into me it's
like
I don't know what is going on besides it
there's a lot of emotions they were
fighting like pit bulls and now they're
crying listen my drinks are so fantastic
they take people to all kinds of
emotional levels from happy to oh my God
I'm having an emotional breakdown
I'm not trying to hurt you but I want
you to also give me love back I feel
like I'm not getting I'm just saying you
know use it I like you I know I admire
you I respect you too she really does I
really do feel my heart so like the fact
that you like say all this stuff like
really hurts me that's why I understand
if it didn't hurt me I would not be
quiet I could give a [ __ ] I would have
walked up from the conversation a lot
at the end of the day I really like
Gertie I've always liked Gertie I've
always wanted to be good friends with
her wedding aside I really want to get
past this and and have a great
friendship with her
[Music]
shooting down
[Music]